[Musique]
le son de la cornemuse et les couleurs
blanchies azur du drapeau écossais 600
ans d'histoire et de fraternité lit
Aubigny-sur-Nère dans le Cher avec le
territoire Celtes le 26 mars 1423 le roi
Charles VII la ville au connétable de
l'armée des causes gens Stuart de Darley
alors on sait date anniversaire le kilt
et la facétieuse météo écossaise sont de
sortie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la mère de la ville a même troqué son
écharpe tricolore contre un tartan un
symbole pour célébrer l'indissociable
attachement de la ville assez racines
écossaises bon nombre des habitants
d'Aubigny oui se considère comme des
habitants un peu à part effectivement en
France et avec un lien avec l'Écosse
extrêmement fort oui 600 ans ça montre
que c'est une véritable histoire ce
n'est pas du folklore et nos fêtes nos
traditions ne sont pas le folkloriques
c'est vraiment la traduction notre
histoire vraiment une histoire locale au
cœur des liens entre les deux nations
mérite bien son nom c'est la vieille
alliance l'objectif a toujours été de
présenter cette alliance comme quelque
chose d'éternel qui fait partie du
patrimoine et de la France et de
l'Écosse
jusqu'en 1903 les habitants d'Aubigny
avaient la double nationalité ici
l'esprit Scottish c'est une affaire
d'identité c'est vrai que le fait d'être
proche d'une histoire aussi forte entre
un pays qui est si loin mais qui
finalement est proche de nous c'est très
fort
à Aubigny cette anniversaire marquant
sera célébré par de nombreux événements
toute l'année les fêtes
franco-écossaises cet été s'annonce
particulièrement animé
[Musique]